- About 280 Canadians had
their accounts frozen,
and so what that
looked like was mothers
stuck at the grocery
store checkout
that had to leave
their groceries there,
which is a mortifying
experience in itself.
Like you just said, you know,
parents that couldn't buy
medicine for their children,
couldn't pay their mortgage,
couldn't pay their
child support.
I mean, I was arrested and
my husband was in Ottawa.
We had a joint account.
I mean, we don't anymore,
but we had a joint account.
So here he is in a strange
city, doesn't know anyone,
and has no access to funds.
(light music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is one of the key organizers
of the Canadian trucker protests
and author of "Hold the Line:
My Story from the Heart
of the Freedom Convoy."
Tamara Lich, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you so
much for having me.
- I am glad to have you.
You came down to the free
state of Florida to do this.
We could have done it on Skype,
but you wanted to
feel a little freedom.
You wanted to
breathe that freedom,
that beautiful thing that
we have here, didn't you?
- Absolutely. (laughs)
- Yeah, that's a
little different
than what you have
going on Canada.
- It's very different,
very different.
Yes. Yeah.
- So, well, let's just
start at the beginning
because I suspect that
you did not intend
maybe five years
ago to be a leader
of a Canadian trucker convoy.
I don't think you intended to
have to write a book about it.
I don't think you intended
to have to have your lawyer
in the studio with us right
now and a bunch of other stuff.
So just tell me a little
bit about yourself
and then kind of what led you
to the Covid moment
where then you stepped
into a whole bunch
of other stuff.
Then we'll spend
most of the interview
talking about that, obviously.
- Yeah, sounds great.
Well, I was born and raised
on the prairies in Canada,
the prairie provinces,
and predominantly
work in oil and gas,
so very heavy in the
energy sector there.
And it was through that that
I started to kind of wake up
to what was going on, because
the Canadian government
is really pushing this net zero
and they were
crushing our economy,
and they were putting
through legislation
that was harming families.
People were losing jobs,
and so I became, I
guess an activist.
We started going to rallies
and stuff like that,
and of course I also was
following very closely
what was happening at a federal
level with our politicians.
And then of course, covid hit,
and I'm not sure about what it
was like down in the States,
but in Canada it was
very dark and depressing.
We were segregated, you know.
I was told my parents weren't
even allowed in my own home
or my children, which
did not work for me.
And people I knew and cared
about were getting affected.
You know, the suicides in
my hometown were so numerous
they stopped reporting on them.
And that's the kind of
stories that we heard,
you know, going
all across Canada.
So I wanted to do
something and get involved,
and I made a phone
call to Chris Barber,
and now here I am. (laughs)
- So a lot has transpired
over the last couple years.
- Yes.
- You know, it was
interesting for me because,
you know, every day I wake
up and there's another story,
and especially during Covid,
another crazy thing happening.
But I was noticing that more
and more people from Canada
were tuning into the show
when I was just talking
about the covid
craziness in the States.
And then suddenly this
Canadian trucker thing happens,
and then it becomes kind
of a worldwide phenomenon.
So first, can you just
talk a little bit more
about how draconian
all of the lockdowns
and everything were in
Canada, and you guys,
you don't have a federal
system like we do,
so it was pretty
much countrywide.
- It was very much countrywide.
We were dealing with some...
Well, our prime minister made
the vaccine a wedge issue
in the last election,
and so he was like, he came
off like a lunatic, you know?
He was out there.
"If you're not vaccinated,
you can't get on a
train or a plane."
People were being
denied medical care.
In Quebec, the
province of Quebec,
they were going to
initiate a vax tax.
You know, they had
curfews in Quebec.
And that was across
the whole country
this stuff was happening.
And like I said, you
know, something so
simple as, you know,
not being allowed to
have your own family
in your own home, you know?
People lost their jobs.
They lost their businesses.
Loved ones were dying
by themselves in
long-term care homes.
They weren't even allowed
to go in to say goodbye
to their dying parents.
So it was unacceptable.
Unacceptable.
And something that
I never thought
I would see happen in Canada.
You know, never before in our
history have we quarantined
the healthy to save
the vulnerable.
So.
- What do you think
was the breaking point
that got the trucker
thing to get going there?
Because when people
think about Canada,
they think about John Candy
and they think about comedy
and they, you know, like Canada,
they think about poutine and
Mounties and pleasant people
that just aren't, you know.
I love going to Canada.
Like everyone's very pleasant
and nice and all that stuff.
You don't think of the
Canadians as being the people
that are gonna push back.
- Mm-hm. Exactly.
- And maybe that's
what the government
was preying on, actually.
- Yeah, I don't think that
they saw that coming at all.
So when the government of Canada
was going to initiate
the trucker mandate,
which was gonna prevent
cross-border travel,
well, it wouldn't prevent it.
What it was gonna do
was if you did not have
a vaccine passport,
then you would have to go home
and quarantine for 14 days.
And so along our border,
we have a lot of truckers
that are back and forth daily.
You know, they can't
take that kind of a hit.
They couldn't afford
that kind of a hit.
And so they have
families to feed.
And so that was
really the catalyst
that started the whole thing.
And my good friend Chris Barber
did a TikTok video calling
for a shutdown on
January the 23rd
and a lady trucker named
Brigitte Belton from Ontario
had reached out to him,
and then just this group,
a small group of people
came together and, you know,
we all had very similar ideas,
and in 10 days we
organized this entire thing
and drove cross country.
- So you're driving
cross-country and now
the mainstream media is
calling you a bunch of racists
and bigots and Justin Trudeau
said that you were transphobes.
I mean, it was really like-
- Everything.
- It was everything at once.
What was the hope?
Like when you all
began the thing,
was the hope really
to break the...
Was it to break the government?
Was it to break Trudeau?
Was it just to turn
around all the lockdowns?
Like...
- The only reason we went
was to end the mandates.
That's it.
Yeah, there was
lots of crazy rumors
that we were going to
overthrow the government.
And I mean, it was awful.
- You guys were picking
up trash after yourselves.
Like it was so
ridiculously peaceful.
- It was amazing.
It was one of the most beautiful
experiences of my life,
a beautiful show of humanity.
You know, everybody
that came to the convoy
was basically a volunteer
because nobody came there
without donating something,
bringing something,
contributing or pitching in,
and like you said, shoveling
snow or cleaning up garbage,
or, you know, it was,
everyone was a volunteer.
Everyone was an organizer.
- So the thing that I think
really put it on the map,
first, they're calling
you racists and bigots
and the rest of it.
But okay, we've all
been through that,
but then this bank
account thing happens.
So talk about that.
Did you have any sense that
something like this was coming?
How did that get laid out?
How did it affect you?
- Well, as we were
dealing with GoFundMe,
that was the initial crowdfund
platform that we used,
and we had an accountant come
in and he was actually trying
to set up a bank account
for us to prevent that money
from going into,
'cause I just set it up
to go into one of my
personal bank accounts.
And so TD Bank was really
dragging their feet,
dragging their feet.
So, I sensed that
something was up.
And then of course, as soon
as GoFundMe released it,
they pretty much
grabbed it right away,
seized it immediately.
- So basically GoFundMe
was taking the money.
You were first putting
it to your account,
but then you were
like, "All right,
I wanna put this to the actual
separate account for the..."
Is it a nonprofit,
or what was it?
- Well, we did set up
an nonprofit after,
but at that time we didn't
have a board of directors.
We did that actually
in Ottawa on the fly,
create the board of directors
so that we could make sure
that it was all managed and...
- And then TD shut
you down before,
'cause GoFundMe shut
you down too, right?
- Yes, they did.
We had a fantastic meeting,
actually, with GoFundMe
on a Thursday night.
Our lawyers were there.
Their lawyers were there.
And we left that meeting, I
left that meeting anyways,
feeling very hopeful,
like we'd answered
all their questions,
and the next afternoon
they froze the campaign.
So yeah.
And then, credit to the
governor of Florida.
I hope I get to shake
that man's hand one day.
GoFundMe was going to...
They came out and said,
"Well, if you request a
refund, we'll send it back.
If not, then we're gonna
send it to the organization
of our choice."
People's donations.
- [Dave] Yeah.
Criminal, criminal.
- And it was DeSantis that
stood up and said, "Mm-mm.
No, you don't."
You know, so, I mean, yeah.
A credit to him for doing that.
They ended up having
to refund it all.
- Right, so can you just
talk about the type of people
that were donating
and the type of people
that were showing up
and everything else?
- Just regular, everyday people.
You know, we had...
It was really the most
beautiful, beautiful experience,
like I said, Canadians from
all across the country,
like the West Coast, the
East Coast, the North.
We had truckers come down from
Northwest Territories, even.
But it was, you know, one
of the most telling things
for me was on the ground there.
It was really a
jubilant atmosphere.
People were hugging and
crying, and you know,
I was talking to
total strangers,
and it was the
immigrant population,
so immigrants from
Iran, Poland, Romania,
all these countries
that would come up to me
and they would just have
this look of desperation
in their eyes.
Very telling, you know.
They'd seen this coming.
They've lived
through it already.
It was kids and senior citizens
and just everyday people.
You know, federal government
employees were there,
doctors, nurses, lawyers,
ex-law enforcement,
former firefighters,
you know, everyone.
- So they come in, they
kick you off GoFund me,
they freeze the bank account.
But then they started
freezing the bank accounts
of the people that donated,
people that in some cases
donated what, 15 bucks?
- Yeah.
I think the average
donation was 50 bucks.
Yep.
- And then they're
freezing the bank accounts
of these people who
then can't get medicine,
can't go about their
daily business,
literally cannot withdraw
money from their ATMs.
- About 280 Canadians had
their accounts frozen.
And so what that
looked like was mothers
stuck at the grocery
store checkout
that had to leave
their groceries there,
which is a mortifying
experience in itself.
Like you just said, you know,
parents that couldn't buy
medicine for their children,
couldn't pay their mortgage,
couldn't pay their
child support.
I mean, I was arrested and
my husband was in Ottawa.
We had a joint account.
I mean, we don't anymore,
but we had a joint account.
So here he is in a strange
city, doesn't know anyone,
and has no access to funds.
So.
- What were you
actually arrested for?
- I was originally
arrested on a charge
of counseling to
commit mischief.
- (Dave laughs) there's
something funny about that.
- And then they had to
add mischief because-
- Yeah, counseling to, yeah.
- You can't counsel
to commit an offense
that never happened.
- Right, right, right, right.
- So they added a
mischief charge.
Intimidation, counseling
intimidation, which as I said,
I'm not a very
intimidating person.
And there's two more.
I think one is disobey a police
order and something else.
I don't know.
- And where are you
with all of that now?
- We have a trial coming up.
So Chris and I are co-accused,
and we have a trial
starting in the fall.
So I'll be going to Ottawa
around the end of August.
We got a 16-day trial
over the course of six
weeks for mischief. (laughs)
- Right, and because I mentioned
that your lawyer's here,
and he did say to
you beforehand,
"I'm not here to
tell you what to say.
You tell your story."
What do you want
people to know before,
I suppose, you go to
trial, so that, you know,
because a lot of this had
to do with public pressure.
It seems to me
Trudeau only broke
because of public pressure,
because suddenly those videos,
millions and millions
of people were seeing
that you guys were not
burning down the cities
like we had seen here in America
and you were not bad guys and
racists and white supremacists
and the rest of it.
- And they sure tried
to paint it that way.
So in the fall of last year,
so anytime the Emergencies
Act is invoked in Canada,
within 365 days they have
to have an investigation.
So last fall, we
went to Ottawa again
for seven weeks to testify.
I testified there.
And the evidence that
came out of there,
the Superintendent for
the Ottawa, or sorry,
Ontario Provincial Police in
the Intelligence Department
said the lack of
violence was shocking.
And he also said that
what he was hearing
coming from the
politicians and the media
was not lining up
with the intelligence
that they were getting.
So it was incredible.
But our mainstream
doesn't cover that stuff,
so that's the kind
of information that
we wanna get out,
is the actual
evidence that came out
to show that we weren't violent.
They were issuing internal
memos in the government saying
that we were entering
federal buildings
and causing destruction.
Like, the lies.
The lies, the bold-faced
lies was quite shocking.
- Yeah.
Well, can you talk about
the media component of this,
because, you know,
for as horrible as our
mainstream media here,
corporate press is
in the United States.
I mean, you guys have the CBC.
It's fully state-funded,
I would argue propaganda.
I'm guessing you probably
don't disagree with me.
But then I was seeing guys on
the ground like Ezra Levant
over at Rebel News, who
they were deeply embedded
with you guys and
plenty of other people.
They're independent.
They're under attack now too.
- Mm-hm.
Well, and thank God for our
independent journalists,
and the citizen journalists too.
Like, yeah, Rebel
News was there.
They were amazing.
True North was there.
There were so many
of them, and I mean,
the CBC is literally
I think two blocks from
where the protest was.
And so they could see, right?
But they weren't coming down
and telling the whole story.
And for the life of me-
- Was there anyone on CBC
or any mainstream channel
that was giving you a fair shake
to go on these shows and...
- No.
- Nobody.
- Nope. Nope.
No, none of them.
They had painted
their narrative.
That's more evidence
that came out.
They had painted that narrative
before I even met Chris Barber
brought in Big Red and we left.
So they were colluding.
The government was
already colluding
with our mainstream media.
And you're right that, I mean,
the CBC is the one that
came out and suggested
that we were being
influenced by the Russians.
And I remember I looked at
Chris Barber heard story.
- It's almost like we've
heard this story before.
- I was like, I don't even
know if I know any Russians.
You know, like.
- You probably hugged some
out on the street out there.
- Yes, we sure did.
- What was it ultimately
that broke Trudeau on this
when he finally
turned around one day?
'Cause it really seemed
like he wasn't gonna stop.
And then eventually it did,
the pressure got
released a little bit.
- Well, I think what happened,,,
Are you referring to
when he revoked the act?
- Yeah, when, well, basically
at some point there was,
I don't know, was that
when he revoked the act,
or at some point,
basically the truckers were
there, they sort of, it was,
you guys were all sort of at
an impasse and didn't he...
Was that when he
revoked the act or-
- No.
Well, what he did
instead was invoked
what is akin to martial law in
Canada, the Emergencies Act.
- Right, so that
was the emergency.
- [Tamara] That's right.
- But what then
broke it after that?
- Well, I think a lot of
it had to do with the banks
because people were seeing
that these bank accounts
were getting frozen
and they were going
and pulling their money out.
You know, tens of thousands,
like millions of dollars.
And I think that he got
some pressure from the banks
to revoke this thing.
- Has there been any reckoning
with Trudeau within the party
or within Canadian
politics altogether?
I mean, I know you guys have
a sort of somewhat
dysfunctional conservative party
and, you know,
things never really seem to
materialize on that side,
but there's been no
reckoning with any of this?
- Not yet, no, but I am
hopeful that that will come.
I mean, I know that the
inquiry is over, but you know,
there's still some legal
things happening there.
They just did a judicial
review of the invocation
of the Emergencies Act
so we're awaiting for
that decision now.
So I'm really hoping that
he can be held accountable
for his decision to
have law enforcement
beat up our veterans,
our veterans,
grandmothers, you know,
and it was such a peaceful,
beautiful protest.
And the footage that
came out afterwards.
I was in jail, obviously.
I didn't see it
firsthand, but I mean,
I got home and I sat it on
my couch and I just cried
like a baby watching
all that footage,
you know, these people
getting arrested
and left in transport vehicles
for hours with their hands
zip-tied behind their back,
driven to the
outskirts of Ottawa
and dropped off in a snowbank.
You know, it was heartbreaking,
absolutely heartbreaking.
- How long were you in jail for?
- In the winter
I was in jail for 18 days
and then I was rearrested
last summer on an
alleged breach charge.
So I did 30 days in
prison last summer too.
- What has this taught you
about your fellow citizens?
Kinda good, good
and bad, I suppose.
- Well, I used to sit on
the board of directors
for a Western Federal
Independence Party.
We created this political
party out of nothing basically.
And so for me, the biggest
eyeopener was, you know,
we've always had kind of a
east-west divide in Canada
and, you know, we're always told
that we're just a
bunch of hillbillies
and they don't want our
dirty oil and all that stuff.
So my biggest eye-opening
experience to begin with
was I'm sitting at
my kitchen table.
We'd all been sent home
'cause it was Omicron.
Sitting at my kitchen table
and I got my two
monitors on on my table.
We had road captains from
every province that would lead
like a contingent of trucks in.
And so I've got these
chats open and I'm talking
to the road captain from Quebec,
and she has like 1,000
trucks ready to go.
And these guys are
beautiful and supportive.
And I thought, this
has all been a lie.
Like, this has all
been to divide us.
And it was so not true.
And then shortly
after we got there,
one of the first pictures
I saw was a Quebecois
holding their flag and an
Albertan holding our flag
and them shaking hands,
and I mean, that
was such an amazing,
astonishing thing to see.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- You know, like the
unity that happened.
It didn't matter what
color your skin was.
God you worshiped.
It didn't matter who you loved.
It didn't matter what
your income bracket was.
We were all just Canadians.
And for the last eight years
that man has been doing nothing
but to try and divide us
along all of those lines.
- Do you think he's...
You know, he only got,
what, 30% of the vote,
something like that?
- Like 31. Yeah.
- Do you think he's
actually convincing people
that he's right, or is it
just that Canadians generally
are just nice so
they don't step up,
that these moments
don't happen that often?
- (laughs) I don't know.
People ask me like, why
do you keep electing him?
And I said like, are we though?
Like, I don't know if
you know what's going on
up there right now,
but we're in deep
in some serious Chinese
interference allegations.
They've been interfering
in our elections and stuff.
So I mean, is he
getting elected?
I don't know.
I guess they're dragging their
feet on that too, of course.
He tried to once again
get one of his buddies
to investigate himself,
and that actually didn't
work out too good for him,
but now they've
broke for the summer.
So, it's just astonishing.
- So when they
reversed this thing
and they reversed the Emergency
Powers Act and all that,
then the bank
accounts were opened
and then did they start
leaving people alone?
I mean, did they
drop, obviously,
you're going through
the case still.
Did they drop cases
against people or?
- I don't know if
they've dropped
any charges against people.
Maybe one case.
But they're pursuing
them pretty well,
especially in me and
Chris's case, very, very,
like they're hard.
They're coming after us hard.
- Yeah.
What I always ask guests
that somehow, you know,
a certain set of people just
kind of step into these things.
They don't intend
on doing these.
You know, some people
set out to do something.
Some people kind
of step into it.
You strike me as like the
step into it type person.
What do you think it is about
you that kind of makes you
want to do this or
have to do this or?
- Well, I love my country.
I mean, I grew up
fascinated with Americans
and their passion for their
flag and their patriotism.
You know, for me that
was so admirable.
So that was something that I
experienced for the first time
driving across Canada and
meeting all those people.
You know, so it's worth saving.
You know, we were just
talking before we started here
about all the people
that are leaving Canada,
fleeing Canada, which is
two words I never thought
I'd hear in the same sentence.
But if we all
leave, then who's...
It's worth fighting for,
and the people are so good.
You know, it was for me
a very divine and spiritual
experience, and the unity
that I saw just made
me love it even more.
- Are you seeing a lot of
people flee Canada right now?
I mentioned to you right
before we started, I mean,
I'm seeing a ton of Canadians.
- Yes.
- You know, Canadians
are snowbirds down
in Florida usually,
but I'm meeting more and
more people that are like,
"Oh, I'm actually
not going back.
Well, this is it now."
- There's a lot of 'em,
a lot of good people too,
like our doctors, our
nurses, you know, police,
like our professionals,
so it's quite alarming.
- Did this change
any of your politics
in terms of
capitalism, socialism?
You guys have more socialized
medicine, that sort of thing?
It seemed like some
new lines were drawn
in regards to those
things as well.
- No, I think I've always
been very conservative-minded
and I certainly have
never voted liberal
in 30 years probably.
Well, because they had a
big scandal in the 2000s.
You probably heard about
the sponsorship scandal.
And that was kind of when I
really started paying attention
to politics and following it
a little bit more closely,
and I was just disgusted.
There's never been
any arrests over that.
Like billions of Canadians'
taxpayers' dollars,
you know, and nothing.
So yeah, no,
I think I'll continue to be a
conservative minded. (laughs)
- The machine has a way
of just going on and on.
That's why I was
asking about, you know,
is there any reckoning
for Trudeau or anything?
'Cause we have that
here in the States.
It's like no matter
how many times
they lied about the mandates,
lied about the
efficacy of the vax
or how unconstitutional
lockdowns were anything else,
nobody gets fired.
- Nope.
- Nobody gets fired.
- No accountability.
- It's a weird
realization, you know?
- It is, it really is.
- Are you hopeful that things
can turn around in Canada or-
- I am.
- Yeah, so where does
the hope come from?
- Well again, I mean, my
belief in the Canadian people.
Like they all came together
in such an amazing way and,
you know, we can make a change.
We just proved that, you know?
Like I said, this was just
such an organic movement.
It literally started off
with a handful of people,
and I mean, within 24 hours we
realized, holy cow, you know,
when we were talking
about setting the target
for the GoFundMe,
Chris had said,
well, I think it was 200 or
$250,000, and I'm like, "No way.
Don't be ridiculous."
I said, "I'll set
it for 100,000,
and I don't even
think we'll hit that."
Like in the back of my mind,
I thought maybe 20 grand.
They would drive across Canada,
stand there with their sign,
get back in their
trucks, and drive home.
And within 24 hours, you know,
we blew past 100,000 dollars.
And so, you know, the support,
the support was incredible.
And like I said,
it was so organic and it
just came from nothing.
And then all of a sudden, boom.
And while the politicians
will not acknowledge
that what the truckers did
changed things, you know,
before we even left provinces,
were talking about lifting
their mandates, so.
- So it was working when
you get people out there
doing the right thing.
You know, it's interesting.
I was just thinking as
you were saying this,
we played a video about
two weeks ago on my show
where outside of the
prime minister's office
they took down the Canadian
flags and they put up
the trans flag or
whatever that is.
It's like these things
really are connected
in a very bizarre way.
Do you see that?
- Yeah, oh, I think
that's all connected.
Everything, the climate
emergency, you know,
that we're supposedly
under, all of it.
I think it's all connected.
- Yeah, how much are you guys...
So you mentioned a little
bit about the energy makers
in the West and the sort
of energy takers in East.
How much of that affected
all of this as well,
just the way the country's
split in that sense?
- Well, I mean, a
lot of the stuff
with the oil and gas industry,
if I'm understanding your
question correctly, you know,
they wanted to build a
pipeline across Canada
and the Quebecois
said no way, you know.
And so that we could get
our product out there
and keep it in Canada.
You know what I mean?
Instead, they import
oil from Saudi Arabia
and these other countries,
you know, that some of them
have some very horrible human
rights abuses, you know,
and that just boggles my mind.
You know, I worked
in that industry.
I know it's not dirty.
I mean, Canada has one of the
most environmentally friendly
and efficient energy
industries in the world.
We should be a beacon of
hope for other countries,
and our politicians
should be, you know,
shouting that from the
rooftops and advocating for it.
And instead they're just
trying to shut us down.
And in the province
that I live in,
it's our resources
is oil and gas.
Like, that's our main resource.
So that affects a
lot of human beings.
They're not just numbers.
These are people that
are losing their homes
and losing their jobs.
- And a lot of them without
these jobs, it's, you know,
some of the life out there,
it's the tundra basically.
I mean, it's not as if there's
a million other reasons
to be out there.
It's for the energy, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well, it's a beautiful province.
It's a absolutely gorgeous,
gorgeous province.
Yeah.
- What else should people
know about what you guys
were doing and where
the fight's going
and how they came out?
- Well, I think the most
important thing for me,
and one of the reasons why I
felt this book was so important
was that the freezing of
the bank accounts was huge.
And you know, Canada
is the most polite
and passive country on the
planet as far as I'm concerned.
So, you know, if they
can do that in Canada,
they can do it anywhere,
anywhere at all.
There was no
parliamentary oversight.
There was no court
order from a judge.
It was just boom.
And nobody from the
banks even resisted.
Like, there's notes in
our Finance Minister
Chrystia Freeland's dossier
that came out as evidence
saying, "Label them
as terrorists and
seize their assets."
Like it's mind-boggling the
lengths that they went to to try
and paint us as, well, January
6th style insurrectionists.
That's what they
wanted, you know?
So I think it's
an important read.
It's an important story.
It's a beautiful story of
humanity and I'm just so proud
of how it all turned out.
- Yeah.
Well, and you're still
in the midst of it,
so I suppose we'll see
how it all turns out.
- [Tamara] Yes, that's right.
- But I assume you're
hopeful that the charges
will just be dismissed and
that'll be it and then-
- That would be nice,
but they've been very eager,
and like I said, last summer,
I was picked up on an
alleged breach charge
and spent 30 days in jail
after I was denied bail
initially then also.
So they don't seem
to be letting up.
And I think they wanna make
an example of us to tell...
It's intimidation, but they
picked the wrong grandma.
So. (laughs)
- And by the way, they weren't,
until recently, I mean,
unvaxxed Canadians couldn't
even get out of the country.
- No. Nope.
- They did reverse that, right?
- They did.
- So unvaxxed people
can now get out.
It's one thing to
not let people in,
but to not let people out.
- Yes.
That's a gross infringement
on your rights.
- Yeah, are you
raising funds now
for any of the legal
stuff or anything else?
- Yeah, well, I'm very lucky.
The Democracy Fund is
funding my criminal case,
and we are also doing donations
because we have a civil suit,
a 406 million dollar civil
suit against us also.
- [Dave] Geez.
- And the JCCF from Canada-
- Who's the civil suit from?
- It's from a lawyer in Ottawa,
basically that when we had
started off as $10 million,
so we get to Ottawa at the
convoy and we've raised
10 million dollars in
donations, which is unheard of,
and all of a sudden
we have a 10 million
dollar lawsuit, right?
And so what this gentleman did
was he started this lawsuit.
- Funny how it worked out there.
- Yeah, you know,
it was so weird.
And then he sent some
minions out into the crowd
to go find people to put
on this lawsuit for him.
So that has grown now
to a 406 million dollar
class action suit against me
and a number of
other organizers.
He's also now-
- But what are they
charging you with?
Like disturbance of-
- Nuisance.
Nuisance, honking horns.
- Even though, right,
it was honking horns,
even though, again,
you guys were cleaning
up and shoveling snow
and purchasing
things at the stores
without burning the stores down.
- Yes.
- Model protestors, actually.
- So we are raising funds
for that so that we can,
you know, start doing,
get a bit more aggressive,
start, you know, doing some
motions and stuff like that.
So, so yeah.
Yeah.
- And you're not
gonna move to Florida.
That's my last question.
You're gonna fight it out.
- Yes. Yeah.
- We were talking right before
about how there's a value
in fighting and
staying and all that,
and sometimes there's
a value in moving on,
but you're in the fight
and stay mode still.
- I'm in the thick of it now.
I can't leave now.
(both laugh)
Although I do really like Miami.
I will definitely be back here.
Yeah, what a beautiful
city and beautiful people.
- Well, we will link
to the appropriate...
What site is it now?
It's not GoFundMe, obviously.
- The Democracy Fund.
- The Democracy Fund, okay,
so we'll link to that.
We'll link to that, the book.
- And then theconvoybook.com
is where you can find the book,
and that's also on
Amazon also, yeah.
- And Canadian truckers
rule, according to Elon Musk.
Right on the cover over there.
- Yes, he's right. (laughs)
- I mean, that must have
been something when you-
- That was crazy.
- Start seeing all
of these major people
that were supporting you that,
you know, you had no
idea that was going on.
- Even President Trump
had said something
about the truckers.
Yeah, that was pretty surreal.
Very surreal.
- Well, thanks for coming down
to the free state of Florida,
and I wish you a lot of
luck on this adventure.
- Thank you.
- And if it all starts up again,
I will still be talking
about it, Tamara.
- (laughs) Thank you.
Thanks for having me too.
I really appreciate that.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues,
check out our
international playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics, watch our
full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.